[Music]
when people talk about ways to reduce
carbon emissions there's one thing you
probably hear a lot
electric
day in america cars most cars are
electric president biden has made
investing in electric vehicles a major
focus we're looking at what could be a
game changer electric vehicles a whole
new era of driving
but when it comes to the environment
there's something that might surprise
you
electric cars are not really all they're
cracked up to be
i think that electrification is a really
important piece of reducing the total
emissions of the transportation system
but our focus right now is almost
exclusively on electric vehicles and i
think that's a problem
[Music]
you know when we think about electric
vehicles we think about tailpipe
emissions right so the vehicle itself is
not burning fossil fuels there's not a
big gas tank attached to it so there's
nothing coming out of you know the
tailpipe to then go up into the
atmosphere right but that's not actually
a full picture of the life cycle
emissions of an automobile or of an
electric vehicle you know in particular
this is paris marx he's a writer and the
author of this book which is about
competing visions for the future of
transportation
marx is saying that cars have two types
of emissions the tailpipe the stuff that
comes from driving the car around and
lifetime the stuff that comes from
manufacturing the car
so electric cars have relatively low
tailpipe emissions nothing comes out
when you're driving around but you do
need to recharge the car so pollution
from power plants supplying that energy
is increased
the hope however is that as the energy
mix gets cleaner over time those
emissions will diminish
but that is not the only environmental
complication
a much bigger one in fact has to do with
how electric vehicles are manufactured
when we think about a fossil fuel
vehicle and what goes into the
conventional vehicles that that we use
we recognize that there's this big oil
industry that is extracting um you know
all these barrels boil from around the
world that's causing human uh
consequences that's having environmental
consequences but often when we think of
the electric vehicle we don't think of
that supply chain we don't think about
what actually goes into it because again
we don't you know pump gas into the tank
in the way that we do with conventional
vehicles that most people use right now
just look at two of the most important
minerals for electric car batteries
lithium and cobalt the extraction
process for these materials has serious
consequences in the places that they're
mined like water pollution air pollution
habitat destruction and ground
destabilization
we've already been warned about the
spiraling environmental cost of lithium
mining in places like bolivia or
australia or tibet and that's before we
get to the social consequences
the world's biggest tech companies are
being sued over child mining deaths in
the democratic republic of congo they
accuse companies like apple google dell
microsoft and tesla from benefiting from
child labor to mine cobalt
you know a lot of countries want to
almost completely replace their fleets
of vehicles so it's not just continuing
to operate these mines that already
exist it's
opening new mines in new places creating
more extraction and then having more
environmental and human consequences
that come of that and so that's a
serious problem that you know doesn't
get that considered as much when we just
talk about zero emission vehicles and
how great these are for the environment
so because of the extraction process for
those minerals
in terms of lifetime emissions the
situation is actually really bad
before hitting the road a tesla model 3
has 65 percent more emissions than a
toyota rav4
that's why an electric car needs to be
driven a lot in order to make
environmental sense
because its tailpipe emissions are 34
lower than the rav4
eventually it will break even and have
better emissions in the gas-powered car
if driven enough
about 20
600 miles
so these two problems electric
recharging and mineral extraction are
two big reasons why even system-wide
adoption of electric cars doesn't really
have a big impact on emissions models
like i'm not saying that an electric
vehicle is worse than a fossil fuel
vehicle it's often the case that the
electric vehicle will still be cleaner
when you look at the life cycle
emissions but the key thing is that
often it's not as much of a reduction as
we think it is
in 2014 a study was published in the
journal environmental science and
technology the study found that even in
the very optimistic scenario that 42
percent of all cars on the road are
electric or hybrid by 2050 compared to
about one percent in 2020 there likely
would not be a major decrease in
emissions
so if electric cars are not all they're
cracked up to be environmentally
why are they so famous
[Music]
there's a lot of extraction that goes
into
creating electric vehicles because you
need all the minerals for all the
batteries for all those individual
vehicles and even more if we're talking
about suvs and trucks
and so you know that creates jobs that
creates value
for companies that fuels the economy
and then when it comes to actually
creating all of those vehicles that
creates manufacturing jobs which are
particularly valued on our society you
know also looks good when you're talking
about an electorate to to show the kind
of jobs that you're creating and looks
good when you think about economic
growth figures gdp things like that
you're going to be transitioned to clean
electric vehicles and hydrogen vehicles
right here
in the united states america by american
workers with american products
and you know that goes back to the very
early days of promoting automobility
itself and why there were so many
interests that were backing you know
pushing cities and and governments to
embrace the automobile over other forms
of transportation
so the problem is not the type of car
the problem is the car itself and the
entire infrastructure the highways and
freeways the suburbs the spread out
shopping centers that are built around
the personal vehicle
the problem is car dependency
if you need to drive everywhere you need
to go then obviously that requires a lot
more energy than if you were just able
to walk or bike or something like that
because where the place that you're
looking to go is so much closer than
what it would be in a in a suburban kind
of environment a significant increase in
people taking the bus or the subway or
the train would do much more to reduce
emissions than replacing every gas car
with an electric one
more public transit requires real
investment but it's not impossible
the total emissions that are produced by
that are so much lower than if everyone
is driving their own vehicle or even
their own electric vehicle
because you know the battery
minerals required are so much less
the production
is so much less and that does require
rethinking the way that we construct
communities
we need to redesign the places where
people live and work to make commutes
shorter to encourage much more walking
and to massively expand the least carbon
intensive option around which is public
transportation
30 people on a bus or a subway or a
train
is a lot more efficient than 30 people
driving their own cars
whether they're electric
or not
[Music]
you